Berni help make you a candidate who beat
Donald Trump by three million votes that
is why this pardon is a slap in the face
to Latinos Ted Cruz masturbates the
pictures of four people without health
care she looks like if Tinker Bell had
sex with James Gandolfini only it came
out more James Gandolfini's BBC
accurately aired an erotic video in the
background of a live broadcast but who
was on that edit Bay
[Music]
Robert out into this weekend so an
honoring our our Muslim friends of
course we need to find where where Mecca
is
[Music]
the newly released tata towel was
designed it solves the boob sweat
problem Michael Moore Eastern SPMD
Robert Lee due to his name how about
just calling him Bob problem solved it's
amazing how smart you have to be to
create something that's stupid
yes that's not gonna get trending
[Music]
[Music]
that's the face of victory after missing
our first show since the first week due
to tech issue horrible yesterday ratio
today we have Dave Rubin we have Roman
millennial and we have na kg air
producing with me in video studio as
always follow me on twitter at not
Google jarred me and it's crowded with
your comments your photo shops your
conclusions I fulfilled my legal
obligations are we good good look what
we have in studio and Owen Benjamin how
are you sir I'm very good Steven how are
you very well well how do you you're you
are I'm surprised that slipped by you
I'm not big into grammar I'm more into
meaning and truth well I guess I can
appreciate that also it sounds like
you're foolish so we have fat Dave Rubin
you're a fan of the Rubin I love Rubin
he's a good guy good guy you know one
thing was Rubin knows you know it's
always going to like his interviews he
can get anyone because it's not gonna be
hard yeah it's not gonna be hard a
little bit harder with this show
sometimes you're like oh yeah we'll do
the showing on a second
you guys who played spot the [ __ ] as
in transgender come to think of it that
was marco rubio's busy click happens all
the time it happened with Ben Carson so
I hear you really like water yes so do
you like drink it to sustain yourself
that's that's so cool
tell me more about water nobody listen
the guy has also created some bridges so
I mean there's a really good guy we'll
be talking about a layabout title nine
Betsy DeVos code I know Trump dak is
going out we don't have a ton of info so
we don't like to speculate a ton on that
but we do know a lot about Betsy DeVos
title 9 and people wanting her to be
raped from the left because that's
tolerant we'll talk about that but top
Twitter trend this morning was regarding
a sign that was broadcast from Fenway
Park in the middle of baseball game that
read racism is as American as baseball
and of course this led to countless
op-eds and Twitter people talking about
how this was the obvious and a sign of
our times racism is as American as
baseball hey said 36.2% of the man MLB
Danny Wright said 74.4% of the NBA
could it be were you defying sports and
a said a hundred percent of the curling
league I don't have them because no one
is watching I just think that guy just
wanted to get on TV and he did yeah it
worked it's a great it's a great sign if
you just want people to talk about you
to say something that you know will make
the view spiral I guess I was reading up
on this and I guess there are fewer
black players and there used to be and
so they were complaining about that but
there are more Latino players been
replaced by other minorities yes it's
like it's just it's like a shell game
like from all the shells so Donald Trump
did come to a deal on daca he says he
didn't even following his own yeah deal
with daca was Nancy Pelosi and Senator
Schumer late last night he said he
didn't but then he did say there were
some talks and Sarah how could be
Sanders had some words to say we
actually do have some exclusive footage
though right right now of the deal that
is still in process
there's a double meaning there I don't
I'm sorry photographer and I settled a
two-year legal fight against an animal
rights group over a monkey selfie
picture so this is this is true was us
judges they actually said that copyright
protection could not be applied to the
monkey but PETA said the animal should
benefit and the reason for that is they
were trying to say that the person who
takes the selfie this monkey actually
took a selfie with his own fingers
should have by law whoever snapped the
picture gets the copyright by law
whoever stamps the picture should have
the copyright you know so but they
didn't see it that way though he lost
the lawsuit twentieth Century Fox has
already secured the rights for the
upcoming film Dunston hires a Jew I you
know Dunston monkey films just make
everything successful but you worry this
happened in Wales yeah was it recently
ales and uh
in the Welsh and the defence of the
Welsh they do a very attractive sheep
and they take him very seriously
I think Peter should stick to the
pockets that's a bad joke
that's a dad joke there I have never had
a pita pocket I've had pizza pockets
this pita pocket instead of thing pita
bread hummus is it the same company baba
ghanoush it's just like a pocket it's
called a pita the same company because
you can't do that many assortments of
food well tell that to those guys it
says they're selling like hotcakes I
guess I've never heard of pita pockets
so people will undoubtedly tweet me
you're an idiot
racism is American it's pita pockets yes
I can't imagine him in the back of that
VHS cover Dunston hires a Jew Oh
Johnston finds himself in trouble
searching for someone with a lot of
vowels in his last name I don't take
Peter seriously anymore apparently carry
underwhelming no no you know they make
me want to eat a panda transgender man
called an Alexander so this is another
story then we'll get the title 9 trust
me it sort of transgender man :
well female-to-male well there you go
you saw easy
sure I don't need to very Coulter
Alexander sorry I was displaying his
taped bet this isn't the top of my Apple
newsfeed by the way I know mine too
like do you have any it's what I'm
looking just at basic news now I have to
feel like Ted Cruz favoriting his tweets
I'm looking at it and I'm making sure my
wife is not looking over my shoulder
because this can pop up you have a
little boy does it ever concern you that
I mean he's just gonna open the Apple
newsfeed and this taped back rubber tits
bro we're gonna start like churning
butter like I'm out man I'm like I'm
opening this stuff to see what the
weather is and it's like this is a dude
with taped it's I'm out I'm out you guys
have crossed one too many bridge much
many bridge I'm out Colton is even his
real name
it's Colter yeah Colter Colter Colter I
don't even know I sound like a sound
like a TV name awful dr. Colter
Alexander displays his taped back
breasts on Instagram in a bid to show us
the beauty of the physical process of
changing sexes so an actual quote was
when the revelation hit him meaning her
he posted an SOS untundi ting a doctor
who would understand the urgency of his
need for testosterone and found a man
who told him where imagine that doctor
someone needs some duct tape for the
areolas okay admit you like falling out
like is this is an emergency right I
couldn't like falling off a lot of like
honey quick poke something to tumblr
make sure the world knows my story are
you here do you have polio no I want I
want like fat fake tits like a vaccine
but I heard that make you [ __ ] no no
Coulter hires a Jew this is another
quote from there we are real people with
real emotions and LMAs and we aren't out
to steal your partner said coulter thank
you that's what keeps us up at night
can you imagine the ego like any like
there's no don't worry we're not to
steal your partner yeah we got it
oh by the way I don't want to pork your
wife and people who talk like this are
always doing what they say they're not
gonna do yeah so it's like I'm telling
you my apartment is very safe for women
it's like who would say that we're not
here to steal your partner that's a guy
trying to steal your partner that's a
woman who wants to be guys stealing your
partner it's literally no one's worried
about this see these pictures here's
here's something that no one wants to
talk about like my wife had a friend
who's gay I won't it was so ego so
almost said his name I won't say his
name but who's gay and it wasn't that he
was gay that I didn't like him it said
he was [ __ ] like he was the gay guy
were the only common ground' yeah but he
would talk about the Kardashians who was
fat how bad their wardrobe was like he
was the kind of girl who would be like I
don't like you but because he's gay it's
a look at these pictures this is a
[ __ ] every it's it's Geraldo
Geraldo Rivera pictures time if you saw
a straight guy on Instagram and it was
nothing but those pictures oh hey the
cathain douchebag like the guy at the
gym who everyone hates yeah there's a
douchebag but because they're
transgender oh wow it's like a douchebag
with like really fat tits by the way I
want to prove to transgenders that Judge
you know you can truly transform
becoming man and put on muscle mass like
I've done weighs a whopping hundred and
eighteen pounds a conversion from stones
like there is no weight class in a male
sport that you could even join right it
is just it's just why are you talking
about we're gonna talk about title 9
we'll talk about daca with dave rubin
this matters because of the fact that
that everyone just wants us to play by
rules that no one has agreed to except
for them and i think that's wonderful
because i think more people are turning
on them but this is someone who is a
self-important egotistical narcissist
taking pictures of themselves putting it
online with rubber tits not rubber i
guess real tits against rubber pecs
i don't know and they try to act like
this is some this person is it's an
unveiling of this wonderful new form of
beauty that we've missed we're proud to
announce the improved kota profile with
reduced appearance of tits through break
through use of masking tape and have
included to her rib cage we've added
facial piercing
and a chinstrap beard reducing
femininity while increasing
douchebaggery by 50% alluminium and most
impressively we've managed to fit all
this into a package weighing in at a
record-breaking 118 pounds the headphone
jack is still there that's all anyone
wanted to know and wireless charging you
can say something before we go I was
gonna get bitter as a 6 foot is a 6 foot
7 man I get bitter looking at how
chiseled that dude is because it's like
all he has to do is just not drink water
for four hours and he's Brad Pitt from
Fight Club yeah yeah it is it is
remarkable what happens when you
actually just get to select I'm going to
take this hormone and not steroids
because I'm a trainee and it's totally
acceptable like imagine if you could
just optimize every single hormone right
if you did it right now you'd be
considered you'd be considered mentally
ill and abusing the law now you do it I
feel guilty about lattes like if I drink
too many lattes I'm like I feel like I
have an edge over my friends because I
have so much energy
am i bombing today I get it sensing
truck we've talked about this before you
know a guy on steroids picture Arnold
picture you know Lee Priest any of these
crazy bodybuilders like the freak shows
to see on magazine covers they do not
enjoy the hormonal advantage over any of
us as men as we enjoy just naturally
over women it's not even close yeah it's
not even close and several several
several times over Google right now
testosterone cancer a growth hormone
cancer I don't buy into it in small
doses but the truth is if you take mega
doses of any kind of hormone that is
foreign to your body there is a strong
argument that this enhances and
accelerates the growth of cancers you'll
see this everywhere and all these whole
foods they will avoid using pesticides
on fruit because these could act as
hormone blockers or mimickers in the
body and bpa-free bottles when I inject
testosterone directly into my scrotum
however although sudden the science gets
a little murky
I enjoy it like at 37 I've had a slight
down tick and I've enjoyed the peace wow
I can like get a stamp collection I'm
wearing Spanish I like I'm not just like
constantly thinking about fighting
people right you know I'm like oh thank
you for stop screaming in my ears balls
like why do we want more of that yeah
only it's just balls and balls until
you're about 35 as a man all right
title nine you asked me this before we
said we're gonna talk about this today
because it's Betsy DeVos in the campus
rape
this is discussion a lot of people are
asking us to clarify earlier this week
but for the same reason when we prep
these segments and now people are mad
that we're still providing relief to
Harvey that would ruin our mo well
because we already promised the relief
money Harvey we were already prepping
title nine and now dak is coming out
we'll talk about that next week
so title nine campus rape is an
important topic because it ruins
people's lives let's set this for people
who don't really know we just throw
around the term and Betsy DeVos and
timeline okay deadline is a portion of
the United States education amendments
from 1972 and this is what it says no
person in the United States shall on the
basis of sex be excluded from
participation in be denied the benefits
of or be subjected to discrimination
under any education program or activity
receiving federal financial assistance
and you were asking me earlier given you
thought it was a sport thing it can be
so broad you know that was about letting
women swim yeah I don't necessarily know
I sure it carries over yeah we had title
9 and I in high school and and like we
had to go through the motions of giving
women like a football team and then no
one showed up and then everyone had to
pretend that they showed up and and
we're like okay on to section 10 support
that women can do with people show up to
watch swim teams swim team swim team
their tits never never so how did this
come to have any relevance to campus
sexual assault okay 2011 Obama's
Education Department wrote a Dear
Colleague letter to all colleges
outlining new procedures for detailing
and dealing it detailed and should not a
deal with campus sexual assault okay so
what did this do it reinterpreted title
9 is actually giving the federal
government the authority to dictate all
of the procedure
is that colleges would use to address
sexual assault allegations they said by
the way excited if you read this go we
have a link to the PDF cited all the
research like the one in five women are
raped I don't know if the 77 cents in
this this is the president sending out
we're gonna reform this because one in
five women are raped yes like Paul was
done it an awful party yes yes the
people reading this do that google
google no no okay we're going to say
yeah what does have to go with one five
right verifiably folks and that's where
that's where you get conspiratorial it's
just a prep does the President of the
United States not know that that's
untrue cuz I know he went to heart I
know he was Harvard Law Review even
though nothing was ever published in
that point it was one of the darkest
people if he's smart right
so this required universities based on
this fall at least false sort of
premises to allow accusers by the way to
appeal not guilty findings which is
basically a form of looks like a
violation of double jeopardy
yeah by the way great film great film
Ashley just Ellen message ed it's great
film she looked like a slightly
attractive older lady back then she
still does today well she did not choose
she did not choose when she gets her
period did you ever see that hurt the
dude I was thinking of face off John
Travolta and Nick Cage yeah I mean uh I
made a bad yeah okay so you can appeal
not guilty findings and it strongly
discouraged cross-examination so the
most important point here is that the
Obama administration actually demanded
that colleges use what's called the
lower burden of proof now it's not just
terminology it's actually a legal term
so this means that instead of proving
beyond a reasonable doubt as we have to
do in our legal system the accuser when
it dealt with campus rape only had to
prove that it was likely basically
possible that a sexual assault could
happen were you alive on Wednesday then
it could have happened jury of my peers
and know she's already carrying the
serta your peers are now kangaroos but
it is true these are effectively
kangaroo courts these are these it's
like Lord of the Flies on campus so this
is this is what happened we're setting
this up so you understand the actual
history but please go read
read more read the PDF that your
colleague letter so what did this
actually do in practice a record number
of people have been expelled for sexual
assault with no evidence at all more
than a hundred people have aura now
suing universities for violating their
due process rights so this is important
because the attack against Betsy DeVos
will talk with Roman millennial about it
hint not everyone agrees with angry
feminists the attack is well she's
condoning rape you see that didn't plan
to pay you see it from Cecile Ridge you
see from all these people on Twitter I
can't believe every woman every woman
who claims a victim of sexual assault
deserves to be heard what about the guy
who's been accused of sexual assault who
didn't do it we can play that game too
you can play like a man either side of
it and this is how they try to paint it
if you somehow oppose the interpretation
of title nine which Betsy DeVos does
which has destroyed countless lives
you're a rapist that's why we wanted to
get into this now what is this done in
practice let's give you some examples
because everyone knows you know mattress
girl right yeah mattress girl UVA the
rolling stone Duke lacrosse so these are
ones that everyone knows but again
hundreds of people are suing because in
violation of the due process right so
let's give you some examples of title
nine abuse that you might not know about
so Amherst College 2012
male student passed out at a party after
drinking too much while he was
unconscious his girlfriend's roommate
performed fellatio I guess will say this
is going on broadcast on him oh she
didn't see now that I said fellatio you
just undid me all that I was trying to
be clean about it but adding them oh I
could have just said [ __ ] Thanks
[Laughter]
someone doubts now what he was talking
about so she texted her friends about it
this is an actual story this is actually
probably even way worse than magical I
don't know why I didn't get the same
press direct quote in the text was oh my
god I just did something so effing
stupid she was worried her roommate
would never talk to her again because of
what she done and she texted quote it's
pretty obvious an innocent bystander now
she wasn't raped
but for using the term obvi someone
could understand why one might be one my
aggressive with her yeah so two years
later after this she accused him of
sexual assault the result the guy was
expelled when the girl's friend came
forward with texts
showing that she was actually
guilty party the college refused to open
the case now keep in mind the guilty man
in this case was never even charged with
a crime so this is another example of a
Amherst College time as she blew a guy
in his sleep and then two years later
said she was sexually assaulted there
was evidence to the contrary in this
guy's life is ruined this is not a
typical by the way if you like the whole
like the timeline is so weird it seems
like if you got violently raped in the
alley right now would you like realize
that like a couple years down the road
maybe guys I'm more that feel like I'm
never falling asleep again like maybe
maybe I was raped it's time for me to
step forward blockbuster raped me with
her over charges and I've been waiting
for 20 years twenty-one dollars for will
Oh check you can't I think there's a law
you can't collect if val kilmer is no
longer recognizable things just living
an al Roker's fat suit and they'll never
find me here University of Findlay Ohio
here's another one in 2014 so jut here's
something often title nine affects
people of my know minority status on
campus people don't realize that what do
you do miss possibly rearrange the
priorities Justin browning and Alfonso
baby the second the second like who's
the first there was no first we didn't
like the name
distinguished the second is his middle
name
two black athletes so each had a
separate sexual encounters with a white
female student one Saturday night
September 14 another party okay
according to witnesses she initiated
both encounters they were consensual she
even came out of the room between
encounters and paraded in front of other
friends naked in the residence now this
doesn't mean she's guilty should be
sexually assault a note that's not at
all what I'm saying don't say we're a
pathologist she then spent the entire
night with Justin browning and bragged
to several friends afterward regarding
the sexual encounters okay 13 days later
she filed a sexual assault complaint
against both men only two days later
they were both expelled
now before even providing browning or
Betty with any chance to appeal the
decision the school actually issued a
campus-wide alert announcing their
expulsion and their names and photos
were printed in a local paper it's like
an Amber Alert for Fey
rape what color would that be I just
don't get why my wife doesn't doesn't
parade after our sexual encounters she
does she talked to me about it
she never parades we talk all the time
she says I look a shame what are you
trying to say we just were you just make
a joke with man's wife know you could
probably reach over there and kick his
ass right no I'm already planning it the
University by the way never followed up
with any kind of evidence and they
denied the appeals again they were never
charged with a crime let alone found
guilty here's one that I find
interesting and the reason why is
because you know we see all these
bullying anti-bullying campaigns on the
Left same people who hope that Betsy
DeVos gets raped but you know the rules
get a little murky so gay male student
University of Texas at Arlington - he
accused Thomas clock it could be cloaked
I could be mispronouncing it here it's
like the Koch brothers my who could
pronounce it that way yeah you would say
Koch Hawk the accused Thomas clock of
writing anti-gay slurs on his computer
during class so basically idea was like
he wrote an anti-gay slur and turned it
over to the gay guy okay he wrote
apparently all gay should die into his
search bar and turn and then called the
gay student it's in it so this so
basically there was no evidence okay the
administration admitted there was no
evidence when clock actually said that
the gay student had been hitting on him
typing you're beautiful into his search
bar and showing it to him clock
responded hey stop I'm straight and
asked him to leave which by the way is
borderline committing a hate crime
nowadays just saying no to a gay man is
seen as far more aggressive than a woman
saying no to a male believe me I've had
this happen in the workplace why did you
say no - uh boys sure no no no would you
a problem with gay guys what no I'm just
I'm just not gay well is that what are
you homophobic I I'm just not a
homosexual this is a fanny pack only
zone though so the gay student was
friends this is important note a friends
with the associate VP of student affairs
Heather snow she then went on to write a
complaint for the gay student and
punished the alleged man in question
without even contacting the title nine
coordinator at the school now Clark
never received a hearing he was
prohibited from having contact with
anyone in the class which meant that it
was impossible for him to contact any
witnesses to corroborate his story
you're something the school still
required him to take exams for classes
that he was prohibited from attending he
was placed on academic probation and
basically the Disciplinary record was
gonna keep him out of grad school which
he'd planned on attending so as it
sounds try this is important because
he'd planned on attending grad school
all of this no evidence the person
happened to be friends with a vice
president over that the committee days
after all this clock killed himself no
history of mental health problems by all
accounts happy looking forward to
graduation moving on to grad school
here's what's important for people to
understand rape is a horrible crime and
I think every guy in this room would say
yeah rape is terrible I don't think
anyone here wants this anyone raped I
think if we knew a man who were an
actual rapist we probably beat him
within an inch of his life but it is
life destroying to simply throw the
accusation of rape especially on campus
where it follows you for the rest of
your life there's nothing you can do
about it think about that imagining all
of your life's plans are destroyed by a
gay guy with an axe to grind who's
friends with someone who happened to be
a VP over there in a title line
department can you imagine how hopeless
that would be this is again that culture
of victims we need to appease these
creating actual victims where's the
anti-bullying campaign here hey say no
to hate don't bully the kid with a lisp
well you drew you drove a guy to killing
himself because you didn't even allow
him the legal tools that are available
to anyone not at your university it is
you were talking about this before when
we did the show was it was a really good
point on when you were talking about you
know you have a choice of as a guy being
them being the monster yeah the monster
yeah I mean I just bummed me out man
that's crazy
well like would you write no no it's
it's just like I I mean that other guy
is such a no but honestly though like
that'll get a celebrity video where a
bunch of people say the same phrase do
you know do you know do you know when
you say it but doesn't matter if he just
falsely accuse a guy a break I was just
in Europe for two weeks so I believe he
was a bundle of sticks yes that's what
they call a pack of cigarettes okay it's
changed meaning for a long time than an
episode of that on South Park you know
give so much power just two words that
hurt people's feelings and then
remove powers from institutions that
allow us to protect ourselves legally as
per the Constitution we want everyone to
be afraid of but we don't want them to
actually have the ability to protect
themselves which hey that's kind of the
founding of our country should
constitutional rights apply to a student
yeah if he's an American citizen these
are the same people who want us to apply
constitutional rights to people who are
not American citizens but we require no
actual proof beyond a reasonable doubt
to ruin a man's life for the rest of his
life and if you speak out against it
you're a rape abala gist this is why
title line is so important and even if
you don't like Betsy DeVos I don't think
she was most experienced we'll talk
about this with Roman millennia I'm sure
she has some opinions when you look
again it makes you kind of like with
Donald Trump it makes me have to defend
her more because there absolutely needs
to be a change here you will destroy a
generation of men forever but hey what
do I know I'm just a guy who encourages
people to rape on Saturday night well
have Roman millennial after this
[Music]
yeah you know I don't even know what she
is I think she's like Polynesian I know
she's half Lexie cares no denying she is
hard to take that girl Bonjour
good day on TV : Bonjour Aloha
konnichiwa he shaded Chinese no one for
eternity must be more than this biracial
life
[Music]
and that list of this
[Music]
man
just want to see how awkward we can make
it reducing here all right in studio you
know where as you love her what you've
achieved well you're so you're so slow
may have to plugin youtube roaming
millennial roaming mill on twitter
because that bastard jack dorsey making
shorten it it's triggering OCD across
the planet are you OCD I mean just I
just have Asian if if I say yes all
these OCD advocates are gonna be like
yeah yeah that's one of those things too
if people say I'm bipolar and no you're
not I know people who are bipolar it's
not fun but I'm not gonna make a thing
out of it so maybe is just OCD people
who are obsessive compulsive about not
having a sense of humor roaming mill 1el
right we're just talk about this before
the break you can't watch yourself no no
it triggers me to actually so you're not
gonna be watching any of these beating
the beast oh it's no especially not
those especially not though well I
guarantee you've gained the respect of
countless fans here just for yeah I will
say this most women respect what most
women are not funny and that's just you
know what is most women are not willing
to embarrass themselves I do think
that's true well I I feel like we this
is mostly guys would be like I told you
beforehand I'm like listen you don't
have to wear any of this stuff if you
don't want to just came right out of the
costume room sick well I'm gonna in a
bra made of seashells well I feel like
once you're already out there on the
Internet
people are taken the crap out of you
anyways right so it's really nothing you
can do to make it worse at this point so
yeah you took a lot of crap and I will
say you take a lot because I think it's
pretty well known that you're Christian
conservative and even though you've sort
of you've talked a lot about this sort
of populist nationalist movement you're
not alright so you get flak from
obviously liberals you get flak from
feminists and then you get flak from me
all right
it's pretty rare it seems like people
have said okay we have to walk this
straight in air right now if we still
want to maintain a conservative fan base
in the era of of Pepe memes without a
conscious decision or is it just
something to happened um I just like
upsetting people apparently yes and
there's actually been videos voting my
mother because you're not a lawyer a
doctor right your dad sorry
hardik yeah but they've actually been
videos where I've managed to I guess
skillfully trigger all these different
segments I mean but but for me it's just
like I guess it's maybe because being a
Christian conservative there are so few
people out there already that kind of
have those views or that think it's an
acceptable way to live your life I guess
so I mean anytime you say something
that's kind of you know even like
there's a lot of skeptic anti-feminists
out there on the internet right now like
on YouTube it's a very popular opinion
to have but there have been videos where
I've kind of I guess strayed from that
and then you know even some subscribers
who might love all my other videos as
soon as they kind of get a hint of that
oh you're not just anti-feminist you're
also this moral standards and people
anytime you anytime you have moral
standards people feel judged so I've
gotten that to where I wrote an article
I was like hey be a real man stop
bad-mouthing your wife and I wrote about
like well listen you I actually I
actually love my wife I actually really
enjoy spending time with her night I
don't think it's very becoming shall we
say just go around and just trash your
wife and a lot of these people have
managed to have respect you're you're a
total kook I'm like I don't think you
really that that term means I like to
watch somebody have sexual intercourse
yeah yes I don't badmouth her because I
like engaging in relations yeah but it's
funny what can upset people now I
remember on Twitter stupid thing there
was this article in Time about how this
woman like making her marriage open made
the marriage even better for her and I
kind of took issue with it like hey
maybe if you want to be sleeping with
other people
marriage might not be for you and I
upset all these polyamorous yes somehow
and it's like really if we can't even
say that you shouldn't sleep with other
people when you're married like what is
there just no I can just have a comment
section they're gonna be using ignore
the comments section because normal
people they watch a video if they enjoy
it they move on it's the crazy view like
in the comment section right now by the
way the compliments are awful I will say
one thing as a woman on the internet the
compliments are usually more vulgar than
the insults yeah true they just like
it's just just like weird stuff dude
yeah weird stuff give me any weird
pictures sent to you um I I don't have
anything open where people can send me
pictures
okay Khan I know some people have their
snapchat yeah open mind is absolutely
not I don't think that yeah well check
your inbox after this I think so we were
just talking by this title 9 Betsy DeVos
you're a woman rape on campus mm-hmm
your opinions well I mean I know your
stuff you've never been raped on campus
right no or anywhere else just if we're
well yeah there's a first time for
everything who knows but yeah I mean uh
so I went to USC in California my
freshman year and the rest of the time I
was at BYU which are two completely
different campus experiences but I live
on campus right yeah I lived on campus
raped on campus no weird
you are a unicorn configured but I mean
you guys have covered us on the show
women on campuses are less likely to be
raped or assault in any way than women
in the surrounding towns and I think you
know that makes sense you look at the
kind of guys who in university or women
because anyone can rape they're
generally better to do better educated
which statistically speaking makes them
less likely to commit any crimes and I
think this all of this hysteria over
campus rapes it's actually kind of I
mean in my opinion is D legitimizing
actual instances of rape right and I
don't know this whole thing with title
nine I just don't think that schools
should be dealing with rapes at all I
mean cuz that's an actual crime right if
you're assaulted you can go to the real
police and they will it will actually
you know look into this maybe arrest the
person like there's a trial you don't
need schools to be doing this at all
right well it was it's what's ironic is
either the same people who just think
it's a travesty of human rights that you
know in Guantanamo Bay terrorists who
are not American citizens aren't subject
to American constitutional rights and
they put them before these human rights
Tribunal's but they have no problem
doing it with a man who woman just needs
to say rape you could be at the salad
bar at your campus cafeteria and there's
gonna tackle and tase you your days done
just a girl even just says ray and
they'll finish it for you
and it's like Marco Polo and you're done
right and what's so upsetting to me
lease is you know after Betsy DeVos came
out and gave her statement so many
people were acting like she was just
saying rape is legal now there's a
difference between saying rape is okay
and hey rights of the accused are a
thing you know due process let's think
about this but in the minds of these I
don't know these crazy feminists it's
like if you like even question yeah that
may be
should sort of look into this before
jumping on board hey this guy is a
rapist it means your rape never lie
about anything ever
I know yeah looks like mattress girl can
you imagine can you imagine being that
guy and you have to watch your your
college graduation from a livestream can
you see that girl walking on out there
with with the UH with the mattress like
Simon with the cross because Simon Simon
there's a Thomas wait who is the carry
as cross I'm for anything that's crap
this is this is not good you should know
this you guys someone I don't know you
seem like a moral lady anyway yeah can
you imagine that Dodie spent Majan being
that guy I think it's horrible to be
raped yeah like no one no one on the
other side of this like no one in this
conversation at all things that's okay
no she only said that during the
commercial break
but the point imagine watching that
somebody like like carrying her mattress
and you know you're like I have the text
right here
a third like requesting sodomy and me
being like no thanks I mean can you
that's just it is apt here's the thing
even though we know it's not true now
that guy's life is devastated yeah and
it's so frustrating because there are
multiple instances where we found out oh
by the way this woman was lying I mean I
don't know if you guys saw this but
there is that a not lesbian who actually
got prosecuted for she sent I think she
accused at least five guys and one of
them actually did hard time based on her
rape allegations she commands him of
raping her yeah I think it was more like
a suggestion one of them actually got
punished at least and now she's finally
you know I guess everything was found
out and she actually got sentence and
everything so it's like it's we know for
a fact that's at least some of these
aren't true but for some reason we can't
actually bring it up or else we love
rate I don't understand why we can't you
know I wasn't a huge by the way he spend
a lot of time in Grand Rapids Betsy
DeVos the DeVos family have turned it
into a great tended the boss's van
Andals people have to hate them because
they're wealthy they do a lot there's a
reason is for the office of the choice a
missus there's a reason Grand Rapids is
booming it's the opposite of Detroit
something we're saying they're making a
bid for the Amazon headquarters anyway I
mean no place really that in the Midwest
could possibly do that outside of Grand
Rapids and maybe she
I'll go now but really that's just a few
Teamsters come in and whack stuff off
your table say you want to go here to
Chicago I don't know why I said I was a
horrible voice but the point is I still
even though I don't hate the divorces at
all they're great people I was like yeah
she dropped on the most qualified for
this job but now again this is kind of
what the left to did with Donald Trump
this is something that should be
entirely reasonable to everyone going
hey men deserve due process and she's
exploring so she's a monster and as
though that's something that most women
would disagree with and there's there
was actually this professor that I think
it was a tweet he he hoped Betsy DeVos
would be sexually assaulted because of
this you guys have to prove some point
oh you want men to have due process well
I hope you get raped
cuz that's makes sense yeah I guess more
I probably like yeah he just wants her
raped on principle principal who
disagrees me and I can tell you what is
it guys I hope she gets raped they're in
a contest to see who can show how much
they hate rape the most and apparently
if you really really hate rape as much
as they do then you don't even need
proof because you hate it so much just
the allegation of it should be enough
yeah and if you really really hate rape
you rape Betsy DeVos right that's the
ultimate that's the crown jewel in the
hating rape so here's one thing I would
like to ask you because as a young woman
you're not married
does it concern you at all that guys are
going to be afraid and you know you'll
be you'll you'll be an old spinster
because no one at any point of this even
doesn't matter how pretty you are how
kind you are like I just don't I don't
want to touch it because all you need to
do is say rape because it worry the guys
are getting turned off from women
they're being scared away from women
they're being scared away from being men
because gonna be mystical reality says
we've seen it this is not rape you're an
attractive young girl I'm sure there are
plenty of suitors plenty of people in
the comment section right now do
horrible things just to get downwind
from you but do you find that it's
changed the dynamic as a woman sort of
being courted by a man well definitely I
think dating culture is completely
different than it was even 20 years ago
and I get all these requests from people
who are subscribed to me specifically
men who want me to do videos about
dating how to meet women who haven't
doctrine aided by this crazy ideology
that teaches them that all men are
predators because I mean it's dangerous
for a man now to just you know try to be
like hey you know how you doing like
want to get some coffee like that that
might be harassment right honestly that
might be harass me to some feminists and
it's a scary position to be in when
you're a young guy and you know you
maybe you don't have a lot of dating
experience this is new you're trying to
meet new people but there's this very
very concerted effort and narrative to
teach young women that they should be
afraid of men that's a good point in and
I think I don't think I don't think any
young women are buying it but I do think
that it's kind of like kids who see
their parents fight unfairly they know
that it's a bargaining chip and a
manipulation - I don't think young girls
are afraid of men but I think they know
oh I just say that he did he rape and I
get what I want
not all women but I do think some let me
ask you this so for you how long have we
been talking it because I was going
going for it yeah 12 okay good all right
because we have Dave rubes we have Dave
Rubin on the show and then we have other
people on and it's just a crazy show
yesterday we had no show because there
was no internet how does that happen in
2017
I mean I'm I've been in Canada so
Tuesday Thursday sometimes it's no power
at all yeah I think just like not even
not even electricity just in general
just peace out I was going to have
internet but that fell down the sinkhole
you guys had sinkholes in Montreal
people don't realize that like it was
like consistent sinkholes there really
deep people just disappear didn't you
people who disappear they never found
sink I'm not sure if they add not sure
if they ever found them but I know that
yeah I definitely that's the thing I
need to grab a few people and go to
Canada yeah for sure the people in
Montreal for six months were little
tremors it was awful
question level questionable level of
development well you know one thing this
is important because people they sort of
gloss over it and title nine was
trending and so Betsy DeVos is just sort
of the person they copy-paste all their
their sort of negative emotions - let me
ask you this as someone you've obviously
probably had guys ask you out on dates
let's say have you ever had an example
where a guy might have asked you like
said to go out to coffee or a movie and
you weren't interested
has that ever happened how do you handle
that
no thank you you just say no thank you
I've ever had a guy like Oh shouldn't
try to follow up maybe again maybe
make a second try and you like do you
feel really uncomfortable if that
happens do you take that as harassment
what what do you see as getting into
that level of harassment oh that's hard
I mean if it's just like a stranger
asking me out on the street you know
there's always the oh I'm a lesbian oh I
have a boyfriend those are great ways to
just have you actually used that yeah
lesbian like one of the movies they go
they do exist I just thought it was
butch cutted Shane gangs who
editorialize at BuzzFeed so who's that
yeah Wow but I mean I've never had a guy
I mean actually since starting my
channel there was this really awkward
like ex patron who kind of that was like
actually one of the first times where I
was actually scared of someone it was
like that level X patron because he was
like one of the first hit the tip jar
you're like oh thank you I want you to
get the Johnson and Johnson you owe him
no sandals maybe it's just the kind of
people I hang out with but I mean most
of not all the guys who you know I've
either gone out with an Adele workout or
they've asked me out I've been in
general pretty respectful and I think
part of it is also yeah I don't really
go out a lot I don't go to clubs and
stuff like that so I feel like a lot of
these situations maybe I'm just you know
I'm not hip with it I'm not in this
that's my problem too I just I just know
is he's in going entirely to the right
clubs and I asked to see his doctor
every other Thursday so your reason I
ask is because I can't ask it too I mean
I've asked his question on this to my
wife it's just something that you can't
necessarily ask to someone who's in
being propositioned like the lesbians
who falsely accuse rape it is important
to note like I understand that men can
be aggressive like that's also not
something that we're denying as reality
but women also can't deny the reality
that I mean men at some point actually
have to make a move you know make a pass
and my question I guess being in college
being an educated person do you think
most women agree with the anti Betsy
DeVos agree that just every single
person who claims rape should be
believer you think most women would
probably say yeah due process because we
certainly hear the feminists scream the
loudest that's really hard and
no just in general I would love to say
that no these these feminists they're
just really small minority but maybe
it's because you know I'm not the age
that I am I'm younger and a lot of my
friends who are women you know I met
them in university they tend to be more
liberal as well I it's not that small
percentage of women that would believe
this and then I mean it's definitely not
you know not everybody but I think a lot
of women would would kind of agree like
oh no like yeah like there's more weight
on against the accuser and I think part
of that is maybe because they've been
indoctrinated the way they have been to
believe that you know just the
allegation enough is like we can't even
touch that or else it's being
insensitive right yeah everyone anytime
you charge an issue and you're like well
you know what no you know no no uterus
no opinion yeah well you know what if
you've never been raped huh
you uh you don't use really know you
don't know what it's like so I will be
neither do you miss lesbian apparently
do they respect Betty do bosses opinion
a little more if she was just a little
bit look at do you think if she liked
would she get a rape card no cuz she's
conservative so that's true they would
just be she would just be like you know
and I I am actually a victim of rape
healing yes yeah well that's your fault
because I mean Oh leave you she was
expressing did you the way she dresses
no she's a white female so you know
someone's getting her back for Harvey
cuz that's her fault
roaming millennial on the YouTube
roaming mill on Twitter and hopefully
we'll see more you more you on this
channel where can people support you
people can find me on youtube like you
said roaming millennial comments also my
website I post exclusive videos there
sometime Instagram yeah hedging your
bets with the YouTube ad pocalypse
posting to your site yeah I you know
it's I have a love-hate relationship
with you too but I'm sure you understand
that as well I know I know I get it some
sometimes I feel like YouTube has
falsely accused me of rape I do
sometimes and then I and then I realize
oh I did do a little bit of it we will
be back after this we have more lots
more rolling laniel isn't she lovely you
can watch them
[Music]
there it is again so strong
[Music]
do you trust me yes do you mean anything
before we go I'd like use a bathroom
okay do I like some math some stuff to
wear I think that's me okay we funded
specific address I can show you the
world like your homeland of endowed nee
[Music]
chai kam Oh South America Thailand maybe
no not talent
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
love him nice guy
well love's a strong word I don't
dislike him and I don't wish bad things
for him no you know I'm on YouTube
Rueben report on twitter at rubin report
he was off the grid for about a month I
thought he was just sore with us I
didn't know Dave Rubin how are you sir
Crowder I just really did not want to do
your show for a month and I just really
went all in and completely disappeared
altogether get it get in line girl you
are not the first person to do this I've
just had numbers changed on me for that
exact reason you got a beard going on so
that was just part of the off-the-grid
deal or did he just a part of a plan
yeah I literally did it I did no phone
no television I didn't know what time it
was because I don't wear a watch anymore
it's just through my phone no social
media no news I knew nothing I was down
in Mexico for a little bit just trying
to you know decompress the brain I
worked on my book got back here did some
gardening I actually connected with
humans I go to though you know grocery
store and I was nicer to the cashier
then I would normally be Sarah what are
you doing with the cashier before what
was they I'm generally I'm thought of as
very read two cashiers that's one of my
things people think I'm a nice guy but
I'm always very rude to cashiers no okay
no penny what I won't waive one you know
when you're online and you know they're
doing their thing and you're just
staring at your phone and it's like a
human is right in front of you so I just
thought there were little moments like
that that I was being nicer but you know
to your intro very quickly it reminded
me of a great line from The Simpsons
when homers trying to figure out who his
friends are and he asks Moe if it's his
friend he goes I'm a well wisher in that
I don't wish you any specific harm so I
think that's where we're at well there
we go I'm very glad to hear it you know
not a bad beard and everything you said
you really go and then and then he
mentions gardening you're like that's
right that's right easy Reuben so um
tomatoes whom is enforcer I don't even
want to dive into this topic I don't
know what kind of sick twisted worldview
people living let me ask you this daca
well you were off the grid you picked
one hell of a time to come back buddy
there buckaroo you got birth and daca
was probably had a hell of a piss stage
hell of a piss Dave probably burned if
it was happening in Mexico
you came back well have you been
followed I know you're not a trump guy
but are you surprised yeah well my
critics they think that the guy who I
never supported who I didn't vote for
that I'm a big shill for him yes
so look tadaka I mean it sounds like
right now that this thing's gonna go
through with the Democrats now it's
funny you know it just goes to so many
of the things that that whenever we talk
that we kind of focus on about sort of
the dereliction of power and how the
branches of government are not
functioning anymore you know the reason
the dreamers got in was because Obama
did it by pen nobody seemed to have a
problem with that on the left then Trump
says he's gonna do the reverse by pen
then everyone freaks out this is why we
should have laws passed by the Congress
as it is in that what's that thing the
Constitution yeah and now actually the
hysteria dies down for a couple days cuz
Trump's takes out a scary position which
is part of negotiating and now it sounds
like they're making a deal with the
Democrats so which of course will then
have all the the people on left freaking
out because oh my god how are the
Democrats how are Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer making a deal with literally
Hitler yeah so I think he's making a
deal just bananas and and strange
alliances are coming in in all
directions these days no there's no
alliance I think he's making a deal with
literally Skeletor I have said this
Nancy Pelosi and I think I've been said
with you in the show is the only person
of ever flat out said I believe is evil
in American politics I don't even say it
about Hillary Clinton about Bernie
Sanders I think people are wrong but if
you read what she believes and how angry
and aggressively she champions causes
she's the only one who actually makes me
sick to watch her it is one thing that
is it does one thing
for me this what's get rid of the kind
of policy for a second you've talked
about this a lot it really puts on
display some hero-worship because people
who are you know he's gonna he's gonna
go in there and drain the swamp roopa
Republicans haven't done anything
Republicans and Democrats are the same
we're gonna vote the GOP out and put in
some true conservatives now they're like
wow Paul Ryan was a stumbling block to
deal with Pelosi and Schumer the lack of
consistency to me is remarkable I will
be the first to say I hate but he's I
hate that there's any deal with Pelosi
and Schumer we don't know exactly what
it is but it seems like a screw job I
don't think he's playing for DHS I think
they've got in by the short hairs well
and you can look at that you can make
that argument from both sides I could
see why the average Trump supporter
might be upset right now by the way I
see a lot of his you know his big people
on Twitter I see them all pissed at him
right now cuz he's making that deal you
can also see why the Democrats would be
pissed because they've painted Trump as
Hitler so how can you make a deal with
this guy so it goes to the broader point
of this team-sport thing the politics
has become is actually are eroding our
way of governing ourselves it's a
certainly eroding the national
conversation I think you and I try to do
a little a little better piece of that
we try to deal with it a little more
honestly and I don't think that either
one of us are partisan acts and we can
agree and disagree on some stuff as
always yeah but what's happening is
because that chess board has been
flipped upside down right now and nobody
can figure out what actually is trumpism
so people say well what do you think of
it a bill say Dave you criticize the
left a lot you don't criticize the right
I'll say well actually at the moment
it's a little harder to figure out what
is the right is the right someone like
you maybe like a ben shapiro type or a
more traditional democrat like a Paul
Ryan or is I'd be more polite since I've
come back I've just delivered a
soul-crushing insult to Paul Ryan
suddely I did it though and it was then
I kind of just went right through it you
can give me eight cents back even though
it's for sure thanks have a nice day
with passive-aggressive all right okay
so but my point is my point is that
trumpism is a whole other thing
altogether so you get you sort of have
to view every decision as if it exists
in a vacuum and
it's not necessarily some broader thing
because if it is a broader thing nobody
really knows what it is
well I here's the thing I can understand
if it's a broader thing if people say
listen I'm an economic populist so I'm
not a conservative
I want tariffs I want economic
protection protectionism I want economic
nationalism which flies and I don't
believe for example in officially rights
coming to us inalienable by Creator
constitutional rights there's some
alt-right people who are like your
rights are given to you by culture I
don't agree with it at all but I
understand there's some kind of a warped
system there what I can't get what I
can't have any respect for some people
to say hashtag trust in Trump or trust
me he's got this believe him
no matter what get in line I don't get
in line for any guy we just we can't do
it Ted Cruz been on the show good friend
of the show yesterday made some funny
jokes about the porn business it's funny
I don't think he did I think it's
Stafford it as anyone knows who has a
big enough Twitter but it's still funny
like that that is one thing the cult of
I will back a man no matter what that
concerns me more than even this sort of
political tea then he just looks silly
like yeah in Coulter who has entire
chapters of a book said I don't want to
live in a world without Donald Trump and
now she has to like okay maybe she does
maybe she change her mind so when he
mary says that that you know yeah idea
real quick on that cruise thing you know
look weather let's go on the assumption
that he's telling the truth and it was
an intern or whatever I assume it wasn't
him but it seemed it's largely
irrelevant to me you know I didn't mean
like if it's nothing illegal then who
the hell cares and actually in the
interview he was kind of being funny and
the way Dana Bash was asking those
questions like you know she just wanted
him to say dildo on-air and it's like
it's like you're all just a bunch of
preening moralizing children and this is
not what anyone cares about and I
actually if anything I feel more empathy
to Ted Cruz today than I did a week ago
and I kind of like him a little bit more
well I know what Ted Cruz is just he is
the he's way better off-the-cuff we've
had him on the show and people who have
watched him like I never I never knew
that he could actually be funny I never
knew that he could actually personable
and that is unfortunate like the swamp
it's all the consultants and the
strategists and the people you know the
Republican experts and think tanks and
they tell you don't be exactly what one
Trump the election
okay well we got we'll move on from this
because we will be talk about deca all
next week one thing we don't know
exactly what the deal is so I know you
and I are like I don't like to be in the
business of speculation they can tune in
to Fox News or MSNBC and it's just what
do we know about the deal well we don't
know much back to you Tom I don't like
this guy Berkley going on obviously with
Ben Shapiro as to how crazy it gets how
much they erupt
I don't know but how insane is it that
we are at this point I mean is this one
of those times where you go I cannot
believe that you know I worked with
Young Turks you're Crowder I wake up
every morning and think that so let's
put that one aside here and say Who am I
anymore
yeah Hey look nobody's perfect listen as
Polly look Ben Shapiro whether you like
Ben Shapiro or not I know he's he's a
friend of the show I'm sure you guys are
friendly privately I'm friends with him
privately and he's been on my show yeah
whatever you think of Ben Shapiro his
the ideas of Ben Shapiro our basic
conservative basic right sort of
libertarian ideas there is nothing
nothing that he says now you made for
example I disagree with him on abortion
I am pro-choice sure so I disagree with
him on some topics that by the way we've
discussed in my in my studio which is in
my home so I this is a personal thing to
me right that makes you that was this
you know eugenics abortion continue
we'll do that next time but the point is
the point is that Ben Shapiro is not
racist he is not a bigot or any of those
he's certainly not a white supremacist
he's actually although he doesn't like
to play identity politics as any of us
do he's actually an Orthodox Jew who
gets more hate online according to some
of these studies than anyone else
now putting that aside forget that
though because I would only want to
judge him as on his ideas not on his
religion or this color of his skin or
any of those things his ideas are
mainstream conservative ideas there is
nothing that he's gonna say that it that
warrants the trigger warnings of the
safe spaces are certainly to burn the
schools down but the media is is feeding
this monster that is allowing anti
fetish show up there it's allowing these
kids to put you know burn down the
school and break windows and do all this
stuff and they're encouraging
they're tacitly encouraging it I did a
video this week because the LA Times
headline was UC Berkeley braces for
right-wing talk-show host Ben Shapiro
now it's just the word braces what does
that make you think of these days we've
had two massive big umbrella term now it
includes looting rioting and felonies
exactly but that these kids have to
brace for it brace for a hurricane now I
mean Google braces for irma braces for
Harvey you they're doing these subtle
tricks and by the way they only use
right wing they only add that and when
they're trying to make it seem like
there's some sort of racist they because
otherwise if they want it to be even
what the headline should have said was
left-wing berkeley braces for right-wing
ben shapiro but of course they don't do
that and people are starting to see
through this nonsense but if you do
anything remotely violent tonight I hope
you know I know the mayor of Berkeley
sounds like he's a total tool go but I
hope yeah you have the absolute right to
protest but you cannot use your free
speech to impede someone else's free
speech it's the most fundamental
American value that there is actually
look at this Dave Rubin came to play
Rubin can be basic [ __ ] but today go on
vacation another month they come back
yeah come back hopefully even not just
always say no when you're offered the
pumpkin spice latte I just grow the
beard and you give me like a lumberjack
now hacking are what you're talking like
a conservative you're not talking like a
moderate first off just for the record I
do not like I don't like pumpkin in
general but I don't like that pumpkin
thing and I don't like the way we all
treat pumpkin things for the record and
I suppose perhaps perhaps maybe I came
back after not dealing with this
nonsense and and now it strikes me as a
little more obvious at the moment you
know it's just look I I performed I did
a speech at Claremont McKenna which is a
small school out outside of LA two
nights ago couple hundred kids there
were no protesters we I would some kids
asked me some challenging questions
during the Q&A session but there was an
absolute respect for free speech and I
think that actually now kids learning
how to think learning how to defend
their ideas and willing to be there to
listen to ideas that are counter to
everything they've been taught that's
actually becoming cool so we need to
stop giving so much power to these
freaks who want to just burn the whole
thing down because if we keep doing it
they're just gonna be more encouraged to
do so well the problem with it is of
course like you said the media is
complicit we have an educational
establishment that's complicit and
that's how you look at Jordan Peterson
and get set and these professors who are
speaking out of course that's anti
intellectual and one thing I will say
you know I've I've been dealing with
this for a long time being on YouTube
since 2009 this wasn't cool for a very
long time the right good example right I
know you're kind of more moderate you
were more left at one point to give you
an idea when you were more left for
example you know a gay man in Los
Angeles I'm just using this because a
gay man in Los Angeles left you are not
gonna face the same kind of adversity
ideologically you may have guys call you
names I'm sure you do and slurs and
that's always Tamil homophobic jackasses
okay we agree but I'm doing it unlikely
that from you Crowder yeah I have well
you know listen I have to do my part I
feel like people are going easy on you
you're getting soft so what happens is
um let's just follow that timeline it's
not the same as a conservative who goes
through higher education who watches
tell or a conservative who works in unit
8 minutes tree it's like training with a
weighted vest because it's always been
this way
I think now people are just seeing it
because the media is just so blatant
with their agenda but it has always been
this bad with the far left it's just now
it's that it's a baby acting out before
they're being put to bed people are
catching on to it but that is a big
thing conservatives I've been so
freshmen with it for so long
when I had a professor tell me she was
gonna fail me Helen Holt because I was a
Christian it was Greek mythology I don't
know how I don't know how I can't pass
mythology it's it's a common occurrence
what did you do did you call it the side
and a lib tart or something no no I
don't come on you know I don't use Lib
[ __ ] did anyone hear a Christian and I
raise my hand should we you're not gonna
be able to pass my class because I found
that no Christians are open mind and I'm
like what what what what cause big bunny
hole did I jump into that you get to
tell them you're gonna fail this
blatantly blatant yeah well even that
phrase no Christians are open-minded
that sounds like a very open-minded
phrase from a professor doesn't it but
you know to your broader point there
it's almost irrelevant to me whether it
was at one time the left doing it
whether one time was the right doing all
that because that just then gets you
into that oppression Olympics thing and
all we
we're suffering differently than these
people in all that stuff so I can put
all that aside what I can tell you right
now is that you consistently see a
defense of free speech from people on
the right from conservatives you do and
you simply don't see it in the same way
from people on the Left if anything you
see more of the punch of Nazi mentality
yeah so that's just that's just how it
is
by the way you know you saw I'm sure
this whole thing with Jamel Hill at ESPN
and then just another way that the media
manipulates things now look she might
you know my feelings on free speech she
could say whatever she want an ESPN can
do whatever they want that up to them I
don't want the government telling me
what to do but then at the press
conference with Sarah Huckabee Sanders
she said something to the effect of well
it's a it could be a fireable defense
it's up to ESPN then the media starts
running on these stories about how the
Trump administration demands ESPN fire
yeah I know and then the average person
sees the quote sees what they actually
said and sees the word demands and knows
it's a lie and then what do they do they
don't hate Trump more they hate the
media more and in this case they
absolutely should yeah
no you're absolutely right it's like the
left cannot become more of a parody of
itself and they're getting rid of
statues robert e lee confederate like i
can understand the why someone might
make that argument I can understand it I
don't agree with whitewashing history
but it was so funny because Trump said
well what's next George Washington
everyone said what an idiot can you
believe in then the next day we gotta
get rid of George Washington from the
park - is racist actually interview I
want to replace him with Michael Jackson
and he was on the news I'm going you
were you are you're so beyond parody you
prove his crazy statements right all
right Dave I know you gotta go you're
busy
thank you saying listen I know
regardless of where we agree or disagree
I do a preach that you have made it a
point to stand up for free speech I like
the edge that I'm seeing from Ruben
today you seem a little fired up Ruben
report on YouTube ruin report on Twitter
good guy and he's got a brass pair we
really appreciate him coming on thanks
so much Dave we'll see you soon I was
just checking the brass pair
I wanna be where my people are I wanna
see you wanna see I'm dancing enjoying
themselves and eating those what do you
call them
oh I think it's ooh shh shh orange
chicken the tapas no told you okay
flounder you can yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I know I know I'm easy to find
go [ __ ] yourself longer
[Music]
let me back from a millennial Dave Rubin
nice show good show Owen Benjamin Ben
Shapiro so you know one thing is we were
seeing the tweets come in right away
when you're talking about topics a
little lighter before we get the title 9
yep
it's funny you always we always see this
kind of rhythm people going why are you
talking about this we talk about monkeys
what are you talking about constitute
you are transgender so why don't you
talk about and then that same person's
like hey I really liked your segment on
title 9 can you feel its own thing on
YouTube and this is one thing where
conservatives do and people just who
aren't the left have gotten it wrong for
so long and I hope that they learn to
correct it here is this being so
culturally irrelevant listen if you're
looking for a show that's only am talk
radio on video this this isn't for you
but that title line it couldn't be
though this is the this is probably the
worst of all the places you could have
ended up but you know the title line
thing we do we put in so much work as
far as sourcing and research on those
kinds of stories and we have a
researcher who we have some stuff
working on now as far as infiltration
behind the scenes that we're pretty
happy with even though it's a comedy
show where we are doing it ultimately
for laughs but sometimes they stumble
across these stories like how did that
happen and you realize just the news has
gotten so lazy but the reason we dress
today
obviously we'll get into title 9 next
week we'll get into Dec when we know
more about the deal I don't want to get
into just conjecture but the reason
we'll also talk about the transgender
issue with the fake rubber tits being
taped back the reason we'll also talk
about the monkey issue in PETA is
because here's one it's that death by a
thousand cuts and we've you know I
talked about how awful that
concealed-carry course was that I did
last week but here's one thing that he
did say and they'll teach you which is
really important to note the reason we
address all of these issues
simultaneously is because it's for the
same reason that you need to be vigilant
because if you're being carjacked but if
your home is being robbed guess what
you're the last one to know what's about
to happen the bad guys made all of the
decisions okay the bad guy has made
every decision he is
- in Detroit where they invented
carjacking he's decided if someone else
pimmy oh he used to say that he's coming
up to your door he's decided that he has
a gun whether it's loaded or not how
he's going to threaten you his exit at
this point you are reacting and guess
what that's why criminals generally get
the better people almost always
sometimes the law gets the better of
them why because they've made all of
these moves before the criminals have
decided to take the section they've put
parameters in place but you yourself as
a victim are often the last person to
know what's about to happen well guess
what you're the last person to be able
to do anything when you are just playing
reaction at a certain point right now
we're gonna it's so absurd to social
justice left can you believe how far
they've gone yeah because he gave him
this rope for a long time they decided
all right it's gonna be same-sex
marriage all right it's gonna be
[ __ ] in the bathroom all right it's
gonna be beautiful we're gonna make a
woman of the year a man all right we're
going to make sure that animals are put
on the same playing field as humans all
right we're gonna remove your ability to
have due process on campus and people
all what conservatives are going well
you know it let's ignore that let's just
talk about immigration policy listen
that matters - what if you ignore
everything else and the right has been
doing this for so long you're the last
to know where you've ended up as a
society as a culture when people say how
did it get this way because of the
people like you who [ __ ] when someone
is out there addressing an issue that
might seem frivolous it is something
that the left has been so effective with
they have been so effective with
convincing us that it's not a big deal
and to not focus on the kind of crap
that they're doing to just focus on the
issues that all of these issues matter
all of these issues matter and I really
am at a point and hopefully you did
whether you're going on going on campus
right now and you're in Berkeley keeping
your head on a swivel or wherever it's
happening next I think I think Milo is
coming to Berkeley I think Ben is in
Utah and I think we have a own Benjamin
is gonna be doing all kinds of shows in
Texas and then across the country keep
redness rule because the last thing you
don't want to be the last to know
and there's a real opportunity we're
talking about this with Dave Rubin I was
talking about on another show there's an
opportunity here to get ahead of the
game but you've got to recognize every
issue that is being thrown at you you
have to see what is happening in these
little incremental steps on a
or basis and don't think that you're
being holier-than-thou because you're
only talking about daca this is
something if there's someone out there
to think tanks who watch this show that
people who are afraid to admit that they
we have it all the time people are like
this is nothing about why just can't
admit it even conservatives
conservatives when we were at YouTube
remember we weren't we were at the
YouTube conference conservatives would
not speak out people that were prize you
they were people that would surprise you
because they were terrified YouTube was
quite literally looking now in the face
saying there is nothing going on with D
monetization there are no biases at
YouTube we're trying to be all inclusive
and I said well hold on a second what
about the fact that what about the fact
that all of our videos are being what
about the fact that every single video
being featured you know from painting
with period blood with BuzzFeed to Fox
News you know it's about a ratio of 25
to 1 as far as featured and
conservatives looked into shut up we
want to make sure our policy videos well
guess what when they take down your
channel you're the last to know
you're the last one to know that you've
been screwed until you've been screwed
and conservatives culture have been
getting screwed so thoroughly and so
firmly for such a long time because
we've lolled ourselves into this sense
of complacency to the point where every
that's what we didn't to talk about deca
not every conversation just needs to be
about Donald Trump there's more going on
there's more going on and the left
understands obviously NBC ABC CBS CNN
every single cable network we have an
editor who worked at TBS he can tell you
what's coming down the pike they've
decided they can always make some
headway by making decisions when you
ignore them if there's nothing else that
this show is about do not ignore them
it's a battle of inches every single day
it can be exhausting believe me it can
be absolutely exhausting but you need to
battle for every single inch at all
times we've talked about this before and
I'm just gonna change what I said one
time I was telling someone listen if
you're on campus or if you're working in
a team industry I'd probably keep it
quiet
no this is the point where you can't you
can't at all everyone needs to come
forward there needs to be that bet that
cavalry over the hill and you need to
fight for every single damn inch that
you can because if you don't and if all
of us don't we're gonna look at our
country as we did
with this last election and say hey how
do we go this far this quickly you were
just the last to know let's stop doing
that we'll see you next week have an
unbelievable lineup Owens actually gonna
be in studio for a couple of days so uh
looking forward to that
[Music]